Molly rocky here your favorite snapchat
life-coach awakening the inspiration
within for free because I'm not I can't
I'm not allowed to charge because I'm
not certified but today we turn to civil
rights dude Mehcad McGann D best known
for his inspirational quotes be the
change you wish to see in the world he's
huge on Instagram like the fat Jewish
what kind of change do I want to see in
the world well for me I go straight to
my chin in high school they used to call
me Molly the chin hockey and Molly Leno
and stupid Molly hockey the girl that
your pants in seventh grade PE and Molly
sucks so stuff like that it's not
anymore though because here we go I'm
here with dr. Jensen doc I'm full of
self love and I love most of my face but
I've always wanted to change my chin
what do you think that's not a very
common procedure recovery times terribly
long but I can say that the results will
be not bad
great let's do it what okay okay do you
have any objections to doing this in
Mexico got a couple hey today's the big
day
the bandages are coming off and we're
gonna unleash the beauty monster you
don't mean do you think people are sure
what I'm saying I hope they put my
molars back there now that's the change
I wanna see hmm yeah good
you